[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com hey this is a super
interesting in some kind of voyeuristic
way I guess Hillary Clinton was asked in
an interview about the similarities and
differences between what her husband
Bill Clinton was accused of doing with
into women and what Brett Kavanaugh was
accused of doing with and two women and
Hillary Clinton said to CNN's Christiane
Amanpour that quote there is a very
significant difference and that is the
intense long-lasting partisan
investigation that was conducted in the
90s against her husband and she went on
to say if the Republicans want a
comparison they have to welcome an
investigation themselves you know what I
find super interesting about this she
doesn't deny that the stuff Clinton Bill
Clinton was accused of is similar to
what Brett Kavanaugh is accused of that
is fascinating to be what what she's
effectively saying is the underlying
acts for which they have been accused
are actually quite similar the
difference is that in the 90s
Republicans thought what Bill Clinton
was accused of was serious enough to
warrant a huge investigation
whereas now Republicans didn't think
that it was worth more than five
business days of investigation followed
by immediately confirming Brett
Kavanaugh to a position for life on the
Supreme Court very interesting on a
negative levels I'd have to imagine that
Hillary Clinton is sick of defending her
husband on this because she's aren't
doing so for twenty years but there
certainly are some parallels here so if
you know this this sort of thing
happened today if if Bill Clinton was
president and there were numerous sexual
assaults and even rape accusations made
against them sure you have to argue that
we have to look into them in depth when
you because we got what Trump is dealing
with and Republicans don't want to look
into it yeah I mean I think I think they
should definitely look into it I mean
Bill Clinton now isn't as relevant of a
figure he's not like it's not like he's
going to be on the Supreme Court
it's not like he's currently president
but I think we have to stay consistent
here there's no consistency and at this
point it's like the hypocrisy ship has
sailed right I don't I don't think it's
interesting that politics and the
Republican Party has become so
hypocritical and this is really a
difference from Democrats because even
Democrats watt by and large said Al
Franken should resign even though Al
Franken was accused of 1% of what Brett
Kavanaugh did and I will remind you
Susan Collins the Republican senator who
very glamorously and famously and loudly
decided to vote in favor of Breck have
announced confirmation she demanded Al
Franken resign with no investigation
with no investigation even when the
underlying accusations were only a
fraction of what Cavanaugh is accused of
the hypocrisy ship has sailed and the
hypocrisy is overwhelmingly on the
Republican side on this yeah and the
cognitive dissonance is stunning too
especially because you can draw
comparison between what happened
allegedly between Bill Clinton and
Juanita Broderick yeah so what happened
with Brett Kavanaugh and Christine Ford
sure both accusations came decades after
the fact I think Juanita Broderick was
20 years after the family
Ford was about 35 years and there isn't
a concrete evidence that either rape or
alleged rape attempted rape ever
happened and so why is it that you have
right-wingers wholeheartedly believing
lauding of a Broderick story you've got
Christine Ford she's obviously a liar it
just it doesn't add up it's inconsistent
and whatever if you have a principle
that you apply to what is your standard
of belief for accusers we can debate
what it should be there are people who
say we should believe accusers 100%
there are those who say trust but verify
there are those who say until you have
DNA evidence you shouldn't believe a
word of it we can debate that and
there's a sliding scale of what standard
people apply but you should apply the
same standard to all the accusations on
the basis that they have similarities in
terms of the so-called amount of
evidence or the recency of the claims or
whatever that's where the hypocrisy is
yes so many people think that this is a
binary choice like either you believe
every accuser or you don't believe any
accuser yeah and I take the approach
that
you don't believe or disbelieve off the
bat you take a look at the case and
weigh it objectively and try to come to
a conclusion for yourself and you don't
always know 100% like even with this
Cavanaugh stuff we don't know 100% but
we can we can see the sniff test and we
can see whether or not it passes and we
can also see which of the two people
have been lying in general and only one
of them had and that's Brett Kavanaugh
which which I think says a lot so
interesting to hear from Hillary Clinton
about that I encourage you to check out
the interview on it was on CNN with
Christiane Amanpour let's talk about
phishing there is this idea in phishing
called catch and release which is that
you fish and catch a fish but then you
don't kill the fish you release it and
there's a few different justifications
given for that one is that the problem
of overfishing is a problem in some
bodies of water so people say I like the
act of fishing but I don't want to
deplete the population of fish so then I
release them there are people who
release the fish because they just don't
want to kill the fish right they like
fishing and it's not a concern about the
population of fish
did I say overpopulation I meant under
population or the the herd I might have
misspoken so there are people who say
for like for humanitarian reasons they
don't want to hurt the fish not
surprisingly it turns out that catch and
release can actually pretty pretty
significantly mess up the ability to eat
food of the fish especially because
usually the way you're catching the fish
is by hooking its mouth with a piece of
food and then you're removing the hook
from their mouth and the fish can starve
to death as a result of catch and
release which is not surprising to you I
I don't fish I don't care about fishing
the idea of it seems really boring and
not particularly relaxing to me so I
don't fish but if I did I wouldn't be
assuming that catch and release is like
this panacea of both doing the activity
but not hurting the fish but if you go
with the net approach though because
then you're not putting a metal hook
through their mouth
I'd have to imagine that metal hook is
somewhat painful and would affect my
ability to eat but I feel
if you catch you with a net yeah and
within less than a minute you return it
to the water this is a vegan here
speaking to you by the way I think
you're okay how do you get the fish to
come to the surface so that you can
catch it with a net you drop some food
on the surface is that what you do I
have no idea I'm asking uh in my limited
fishing experience I'd have to imagine
you leave something on the surface they
all come up and then you catch the
entire thing but I could be completely
wrong here it's kind of funny how like a
proper study had to be done of this it's
like is haven't we known for a while
that when a hook goes through a fish's
mouth it can leave the fish both sort of
stunned and also hurt its mouth which
you need for eating like didn't really
need I'm not I'm not one of these people
these people who says we shouldn't fund
studies and to really niche things I'm
just saying aren't the results sort of
obvious here people just think that
because it's happening through an animal
that the animal doesn't feel pain or
experience it in the same way that we
necessarily regardless you can believe
that the animal doesn't feel pain but
that the mechanics of having a hook
through your mouth impacts your ability
to feed you you you could argue that it
doesn't hurt the fish but it hurts its
ability to eat right ya know and some
people would say you don't have to feel
bad for the fish because it just
inhibits their ability to eat other
smaller fish sure and I think we should
just stay out of it altogether but the
point is you have to you have to think
about the ecosystem here and if that
fish isn't able to eat the smaller fish
then that's going to have ramifications
for the entire ecosystem think about how
many small fish are saved every time you
you put a hook through the mouth of a
slightly larger fish and drop it back
into the water that's crazy that's a lot
of fish little flute allure fish that
you've just saved do you think we have
bigger fish to fry maybe I think that
that may apply here yeah it seems that
it's not just Rand Paul who's kind of a
wacky guy the wife of Senator Rand Paul
now says that she has upgraded her home
security and also sleeps with a loaded
gun by her bed because she's worried
about violent liberals as a result not
of you would think okay that
anesthesiologist or whatever I think was
an anesthesiologist tackled Rand Paul a
year ago or a few months ago and broke a
rib of his right at his
one so that's why Rand Paul's wife now
is really worried she's worried about
her neighbor or something like that no
the political climate and so-called
violent liberals are what is making her
upgrade her home security system and
keep a loaded gun by the bed okay well
it does have some overlap with the
protests in public places of Trump
officials and of Senators we've seen it
happen with Kristin Nielsen jarhead Cruz
Stephen Miller Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and you know I like that approach to
some degree I don't want it to get to
the point of like harassment or
intimidation and I certainly want all
the way yeah you don't want people going
to these people's houses and I think
that's where the problem comes in I
think that if you're standing on the
sidewalk it's very what what she's
talking about here is breaking into
someone's home right like that's not a
question of decorum that's a crime
you should get arrested for that you
should be charged for that and the
judicial system should figure out
whether you need to spend time in jail
or prison or result like we're talking
about orders of magnitude something else
which has not happened right that's the
weakened debate you know Jeff Flake was
confronted in an elevator then all of a
sudden he wants an investigation into
Kavanaugh did it work did it have an
effect is it appropriate inappropriate
what's the effect no one's talking about
breaking into politicians homes that's a
crime you shouldn't do it and if you do
police should arrest you well shortly
after the Democrats did a poor job of
defending the dreamers against the stuff
that Trump wanted to do yeah there were
protesters who showed up outside of
Chuck Schumer's apartment and they were
chanted and you know this is a big New
York City apartment so you don't have I
don't think he's really at any risk
there so their electors are showing up
at Rand Paul's house let's say yeah on
the outside you would be worried right
and I don't know if I would sleep next
to a loaded gun I'd be more worried
about like waking up from a nightmare
and shooting someone but it would
certainly be intimidate or II and I
would presume that you know Senate
security would get involved and they
would assess the situation and figure
out what do we need to do to make sure
that Rand Paul and his family are safe
so she really is just crazy here there's
no just listen it's not it's just funny
it's sort of funny to me that Rand Paul
was attacked by a neighbor who I think
was a Republican
and she gets a gun because of amorphous
violent liberals that might break into
her house where we've not actually seen
a desire or willingness for that to be
done at this point yeah I kind of
overlaps with that thing about how
you're more likely to be a victim of a
crime perpetrated by someone you know
versus just some random stranger sure
like apparently that even applies to
senators too maybe so apparently it
applies to Rand Paul that appears to be
for sure okay that's really it for today
is there anything else that we need to
go over I don't think so we talked about
the the already potentially destroyed
political debate after making the big
announcement yesterday we talked about
that on the Regular Show I don't know if
there's anything else to discuss almost
like every single day we're gonna have
to have a political assignment yeah even
after politican I think they're gonna be
changes made yeah that we're gonna have
to cover I think there are and I am
considering change as I mentioned I
might already be changing my flight back
and you can be sure I will ask them to
cover my $200 flight change fee I'm
actually hoping to set the record for
most flight changes for a single flight
like I've already moved my flight once
it would be great to have to move it
like two or three more times to the
point where they incur like $800 in
flight change fees this could be really
an incentive politican to get it stuff
together next year I agree if nothing
else does it
looking unprofessional and you know
making all the guests pissed off if that
doesn't do it just the accumulation of
having to pay these change like change
fees I think that'll do it
there's no way in hell I'm getting
invited next year right like that I'm
sure they're totally sick of dealing
with me even though I'm not really the
problem I'm just saying it would be
great if you could tell me what I'm
doing so that I can make fixed plans
well I think other people are maybe
getting under their skin too yeah it's
not just me Kyle Quinn's calculon scheme
maybe so yeah his I saw his video about
his demands
if I were then I would probably be
irritated with all of us I hope it's not
just the lefties that are bothering them
with uh requests from itineraries go
figure you get the sense that just about
everyone else and not just new media
figures on the left but people like Ann
Coulter and David from they're all so
agitated by the fact that they don't
know what's going on I was talking to
Kyle and I said do you think this is
just going on with the left winners and
he said I think it's going on with
everybody I hope that's
because otherwise we're gonna give
ourselves a bad name do you think those
other people care as much though I don't
know maybe they're used to it maybe all
these public appearances Oh Latonya more
on tomorrow's politican segment if there
is another third segment to read the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]